You are listening to radiolab radio
from the beginning. W N Y. S t. E
n n. P. R. E.
You ever get a good sense of what to what
you want to tell me? Yeah. All right.
Hey, I'm Jen. I am Robert. This is
Radiolab, the podcast, the podcast.
Can I just start us off with
a moment of appreciation?
I'm very excited for what you're going
to play for us today because sometimes,
you know, you talk to people
on stage smart people and uh,
you did one recently for the
world science festival. Yes.
And we put it on every so often on the
podcast, but we don't do it enough. Well,
we're going to do it now.
So
in, in just a moment,
I'm going to introduce you
to two gentlemen who are
nothing short of remarkable,
but before I do, I'd just,
so we go now [inaudible] and Sylvia k
auditorium at the campus at Hunter College
in Manhattan. Uh, Louise and we'll
just set it up for us a little bit.
Like what are we about to
do? Um, well, so the, the,
the idea of this world
science festival evening, um,
there are people who wander around the
world who have a problem which is called
face blindness. Weirdly, both
these men are face blind.
So when they look at a face
for 10, 20, 60 minutes,
the other guy's face just doesn't
get in or sticking to their heads.
I chose two people.
One of them is Oliver sacks
are irregular. Oliver,
he's a neuroscientist and he's
like all over his Facebook.
Oh boy is he phased by it?
I mean he came recognize faces but you'll
see the other guy who we are going to
call chuck, the other guy is one of the
greatest portrait artists in the world.
He has as many of you know for
decades now created art big paintings.
I'm little but usually huge
paintings, mostly of faces.
Here he is chuck close.
I thought it would be interesting
to bring these two people together,
face blind,
Oliver face blind shot and discuss what
many people think of as a very rare
situation. Lauren. It does. Again,
we don't know who you are yet.
Both of you.
How long ago did you discover
if indeed that's the right word,
that you were unusual in
this regard? I'll, um,
I think probably when I, hi, I can't
hear. Okay. So I'll tell you what,
I'll just stick this thing in front of
you and say something. Say something.
That's all you missed the first part of
the program. But all of it was saying,
uh, so you, you were in a class
with other kids. If you, if,
if you had a friend who
was like, you know, a pow,
would you take a bit a beat
to know who it was when? Yeah.
So say Jonathan Miller became a
good friend. He's tall and gangly.
He has red hair and
his, his movements, uh,
are fluid and evocative and wonderful.
And if Jonathan Miller was brought
in paralyzed and totally straight,
would you know it was Jonathan
Miller? Do you have to see the hair,
the movements? No.
Um, when I, when I have got to
know someone, well, uh, then I,
then I will recognize the face, but
it takes a long while and with, um,
and even mirror has to be reinforced.
Right. You have to keep saying.
So if you spent four minutes with the
person and you walk away and come back two
minutes later, do you
know who the person is?
It does if 20 minutes with the person
time make a difference, um, uh,
I tend to lose it within
minutes. Every minute you,
same problem. Same problem. I um,
I can spend an evening talking to someone,
looking at them across the table
and I've see them the next day.
I'd have no idea I've ever seen
them nor do I remember their name.
But when they open their
mouth, would you say, oh,
that's the one or not even know.
And a lot of it is context.
If they walk into my studio,
I figured they've walked into my studio
because they're supposed to be there.
Alright.
Then I interview them for a
while to find out who they are.
Are you just trying to subtly
find like, so who is the,
is that this whole is this person? Why
are they in my studio now in your case,
if that person were to suddenly flatten
out and [inaudible] still on a page.
The thing in my work is I'm determined
by my learning disabilities.
So face blind.
I'm sure I was driven to paint
portraits by being faced blind. Uh,
that is, I am, I know
now that if I can, uh,
flatten an image out and
scan it the way I work,
I can commit it to memory and I have
almost photographic memory for things that
are flat and still still, yeah.
Three being in space and moving
around makes the face and visible.
Fixing it makes the face men
move your head a half an inch.
To me it's a whole new, yeah.
Face I've never seen before. Wow. Wow.
Have you ever not recognized
yourself? Um, yeah, I'm,
I'm always, um, well,
several times I have started apologizing
to launch clumsy at people and realize
that it's a mirror. It's a
mirror, it's a mirror. Um,
but it's even going to stage further
than that. Fairly recently. I was, uh,
in a, uh, a cafe in Chelsea
market with tables outside. And,
um, while I was waiting for my food,
I do what people would be as often to,
I started to, to preen myself.
And when I realized that my reflection
was not doing the same thing
[inaudible]
well should I, and the inside there
was a man with a beard. Possibly you?
No.
Who wondered why I was sort of, you know,
making faces with him, so,
so I may take out the people to be
myself as well as fun. Nice. My,
I just was wondering how you result
once you realize that you were preening
your beard in front of the bearded man.
Um, did you, could you, did you
like look down and I, yeah, I,
I did look abashed I often put dashed.
Well, now let me just ask you
about, is this just a face problem?
What about emotional? Can
you, if you can't see a face,
can you ever read sadness? Happiness?
Yeah, I don't think I have any trouble
reading, um, how someone is feeling.
I think I'm actually pretty good at
that. You know what the, the way,
the way I work is to make this kind of
Bob Dick Maillian world in which I make
the face into a landscape.
And I journey across that landscape like
Gulliver's Lilliputians crawling over
the face of a, of a giant,
not knowing that they were
on the face of a giant,
but knowing everything about that face.
And then what I do is I put all that
information together or the kind of knows
the nostril, low corners of the
mouth, whatever, and I can commit it.
I can commit it to memory.
So I know that this is no accident
that I was driven to make, um,
uh, portraits of people who matter to me
can, but if,
if the person who's face you can't
read lips are trembling or if they are,
have a downcast look in the
eye or if they're being brave,
can you assign emotion to
a facet of a face? Yeah.
And you too. Okay.
Well, I look talked at Mike. Okay, well I,
I can't paint or whatever, but I think
I'm a sensitive to emotions. You know,
and, and,
and little things including little
grimaces which indicate that someone is,
is lying or here's a difference.
I sent this to complete this sort of
look of what you can and can't do.
Oliver can remit. I, when I ask you
about things you've written 22 years ago,
a lot of times if you've talked to an
author about something they wrote 22 years
ago, they give you a sad look of, you
know, well, that was a long time ago,
but you seem to remember much
of what you have learned.
You seem to remember
very little of what you
before.
Well, let me, let me, let me
be gentlemen about that. Ah,
when you were in high school, it
was time to take the test, right?
You once to describe to me a,
um, an all night bathtub. No,
I
used the kind of sensory deprivation
tank in order to memorize things and um,
uh, it's very hard for me. I'd still,
I don't know how to add or subtract
without using the spots on dominoes of
visual system. I still don't know
the multiplication tables. Um,
I didn't take Algebra, geometry, physics,
or chemistry at the junior
college in my hometown. Didn't,
I had not taken every
taxpayer, his son or daughter.
I could never have gone to college.
Wow. So you're a wreck. Yeah.
Yeah. But
that's the coping part
of this for both of you.
It's been kind of interesting because
both of you are very, very smart.
So you just put your
intelligence where you have,
one of the great quotes I've
ever heard this from, uh, the,
the great painter Robert
Rauschenberg, who was, uh, the,
about the most learning disabled,
a dyslexia person I've ever known.
And he said, when you're this way,
you have to find other venues
for your intelligence, right?
You have to prove to your
teachers that even, Oh,
you're not going to be able to spit
back the name of the names or dates that
you, that you care about the material.
And we have to prove to the people
who we see that we care about them,
even though we're not going to recognize
their faces and maybe remember their
names. So you have to be charming.
You have to be a bullshit.
Yeah,
you have to be fast on your
feet and figure out how
you're going to explain your
way out of the fact that you don't,
uh, know who they are or remember them.
Do you find people calling you
like a snob or I mean like,
like what do you mean you don't know me?
I'm the host of this
dinner party kind of thing.
Um, yes. Um, usually my,
my assistant cakes will say to people
beforehand, before they come in,
don't ask if, if he remembers
you because he'll say no to me.
She says, don't just say no.
Say I'm awful with faces. I
wouldn't recognize my own mother.
Um, but I am, but I'm not good at. Okay.
Um, yeah, I, I tend to withdrawal.
You withdraw. Yeah. So you,
you solve it by going into a corner
and not talking to anybody. Well,
it doesn't solve it. I just
talked to makes it worse. But, um,
my approach is to be more
outgoing, more friendly, whatever,
and to try and, um, charm my way, uh,
through things.
And I also lecture and talk all the
time about face blindness and my other
problems. So that people are
aware that I have then Manhattan,
they'll cut me some slack.
But, but, but you, you go out
like every chance you can. Right.
And you stay in every
chance you can write well,
more or less. Yeah. No
I don't stay in, but I,
there are other things
besides human beings.
And um,
when, when for example, I first
visited Australia, I came back with,
with hundreds of photos and people
look through with [inaudible]. Yes.
But didn't you meet any
human beings? Books?
All my photos were of scenery
and plants where I'm very at home
and I, I noticed that when you get
in the elevator, in your apartment,
you don't have any idea who the neighbors
are, but you do look down. Right? Oh,
I know that dogs.
So if they were to switch
dogs, you'd just be a, yeah.
Well I wouldn't notice. Yeah.
But if you see them without the dog,
you don't know who they are. No,
I don't know. So,
so this charm offensive that you go on,
what does that like how if you
have no idea who you're talking to,
what are they, what are the
charm moves? Well, not always
charming. I didn't recognize
a woman I'd lived with
for a year, two years, two years later,
and there's no amount of charm,
but it's going to get you through
a mistake like that.
It's like, do you just,
do you make fun of yourself? Oh yeah.
Self deprecating humor will,
will cover a great deal.
And um, if you laugh at yourself,
you're giving permission to other,
for other people to see it as less
than the most tragic a condition.
It, it is funny. You know, it's
funny, I wish I didn't have it,
but it's funny.
What am I,
am I that I'm lots of neurological
conditions are all comic.
They can be both awful and comic and it's,
well, there's a gallows humor in
rehabilitation hospitals for that,
for that very reason. You know,
what about it that's narrowed
down the techniques here at,
can you sometimes not see
the face but see the hair,
the ears, the something?
Oh, I'm, I'm a, absolutely.
If someone has large out
sticking ears or hook nose or,
or a little triangle of beard, uh,
off the glasses of a particular sort,
um,
I'm better at recognizing cow couture's
and portraits book say in a caricature.
Salient features are
exaggerated. And for me it's, uh,
to some extent I have to make an
inventory of salient features.
You talk about Gulliver and that process.
Do you think of what you
do as an expression of the
situation you find yourself
in?
Sure. In every way. I mean, I'm, uh,
I have trouble, uh, in a
global sense with the whole,
but if you break it down into
small enough bite-size, uh, units,
incremental units,
then I made this big overwhelming problem
into thousands of little more solvable
problems. I've just found
a way to, um, you know,
take my deficits and uh,
and use them rather than the
Bang my head against the wall.
Let me,
let me show you lie all this is
Chuck 15 and then the truck 16.
So the truck 15, it's going to be a
person you know named who is liable. Wait,
now what's happening? What
is this right here? So yeah,
what you should do is
you should imagine a, um,
it's a detailed slide and what you see
is lots of boxes with almost like mirror,
like shiny nuggets in
each mocked as this one.
You're looking at a checklist
painting really close.
Is that what you're
describing? Yes. It's a detail.
So it's the lower lip
and chin of somebody.
Somebody who he calls the while when
people stand right in front of Lyle's
mouth, there's a little bit of
confusion. You can't quite read it
right away. Well,
the closer you get the something
normally the more information you'd get,
but the closer you get, the one on
mine, the less information you have.
You have information.
When you step Mack,
these very abstract flat little cells
suddenly turn into a very interesting
phase. Well, here's what I don't
understand that if he's blind to the face,
how do you even build it up?
Like don't you have to be able to see
the thing that you're building too.
If he can fix it, which
the photograph does.
Oh he takes a picture first he
takes a picture first and then what?
Then he graphs it. So he makes
it into lots of little boxes.
It looks like a giant checkerboard and
then he goes to into each checkerboard
and he then repaints it magically when
you step away there is the thing that you
can put. Interesting. So he's able to,
he's able to see the details within
those boxes well enough to be able to
construct them and then trust. Then
what will emerge as the face, the,
and the magical part is not only do you
suddenly get the reveal of the face,
but with the reveal comes
a sense of the person.
Okay, so let's go back to the situation.
So now all the way you have been
losing your depth perception.
So he, he's now go,
he takes where the world in three D and
puts it into two D in all these fleshy
and interesting ways. You have
always been all your life or 3d man,
cashiers here passionate.
What's happening to you now?
Well now I've lost the
sight of one eye. Um, I'm,
everything for me is on a
plane and on a flat surface.
Does that mean that when you look at art,
that things that used to bore you now the
flat things getting better and spacial
things get worse? We'll the has
been a a paradox. Um, and that, uh,
for me previously until a few months ago,
the world consisted of solid objects
residing in space and with space between
them. Uh,
now the objects are as well painted on,
are on a flat plane.
And I think that the sense
of visual composition, uh,
which is not a word I ever use or
to the concept I ever had strongly.
I think that is stronger.
Unfortunately I can't paint,
but I do in fact find myself
enjoying painting small,
especially sort of are
the flat medieval ones.
I partly feel I'm in a sort of 13th
century world and I'm sitting here with
one eye closed, which is what I've
done my whole life. Right. Well,
because I have double vision if I
have both eyes open and uh, you know,
so I closed one eye and I flatten the
world out and I have a much better chance
of getting around in it.
So you see the wrinkles on this aisle
because it's been closed virtually my
entire life.
Oh, okay. Well, by the way,
is there any cure for this that
we know that if you have this,
if this facial blindness,
does anyone get cured of it?
Not so far as I know.
Okay. Empty. But, you know,
I think it's important to
say, and, uh, you know, I,
I portrayed myself as sort of as
is withdrawn or helps us, but I,
I think I also have a, a vivid love
of humanity as chuck has. But for me,
the portraits take the form of
narratives, the stories smell, um, you,
your words paint the most, uh,
specific portraits of
people's lives. And, uh,
I always have identified
your characters as a,
as vivid portrait, as anything anybody
could do in any other art form. And uh,
um,
we [inaudible]
you celebrate your connectedness with
humanity in a really important way.
I mean, it's a way that
we can identify with,
even if it's a problem we don't have.
Empathy is the basis
of I think the mortar,
that whole society together and uh,
telling stories in a riveting way that
allows us to empathize and care about
these people up. My, my grandfather
had Tourette's syndrome and reading,
uh, about a character with Tourette's
syndrome. And what are your books?
I cried through the whole thing.
Hm. Um, can I ask about the
cause of this condition?
You can get face blindness from a stroke,
right? Can you get it from a tumor?
Ah, yes, yes. Well,
head injury or whatever affects
a particular part of the brain.
A small area in the, in the
visual Cortex, people call it the,
the fusiform gyrus,
the fusiform face area.
Actually there are a number of different
face areas and normally these connect
up with memories of faces and things. Um,
but something which was not recognized
until very recently and it's still very
insufficiently recognized
is what chuck and I have,
which has lifelong face blindness
and which is often strongly familiar.
And there if you do strongly
familial meaning genetic perhaps.
Yes. How widespread is this
condition? The tooling you have it,
the best estimates is
that fairly severe? Um,
I mean the May well abuse a
symmetrical curve. Uh, um,
chuck and I are in the worst two or 3%,
but probably not the worst 1%. There
are people who are far, far worse.
Um, but um,
so you're going to give me a guess when
you think it's like 10% of the world and
1% a,
the fairly severely affected
people are two to 3%,
which is six to 8 million
people in this country.
Well, let's, let me,
let's do a test to see whether this
audience, how, let's just see how,
how good or bad you guys are. We're going
to do a little fun test of your face.
And the way it works is the 10
celebrity faces. What does that show?
Here's what happening. We decided to
give the whole audience a face test.
10 celebrity faces will be flashed
on the screen for 15 seconds.
Each took 10 very famous celebrities.
They included the president of
the United States of America.
Fabulous movie stars from
the past and the present.
You just put their face up and say, do
you recommend we put their faces up?
But we erased here. Here, Huh?
Oh, just the face. Only the face.
That's interesting. So imagine like
Johnny Depp, but no here takeaways here.
The question is would they rent?
Would you recognize this person?
I've been thinking how we think people
would recognize. I mean, well so when I,
but when I read out the names,
you're hand reading out the names.
Number six is Johnny Depp, Johnny Duh.
That's what he's like without hair.
That's what he's like without here.
People Sound surprised. I'm going to
ask for a show of hands. All right now.
And so then I said, well please raise
your hand if you got any person, right.
Anyone at all. You know,
almost everybody. Oh,
maybe lower your hand if you
only got one or two. Right?
Okay. So now some hands go down.
Lower your hand if you only
got three, right? So now, yeah,
we're beginning raising this in
an odd way. Only got three, right?
Lower your hand if you only got four,
right? Oh, he is such a funny word.
Yeah. Thank you, chuck.
Going please now lower your hand
if you only got nine rights.
The remaining hands with how
many hands are up at this point?
That's six out of like a
thousand. Yup. How many?
The remaining hands I got in CN. Could
you stand if you got 10 I just like this,
but the number of
people, but wow, they're all women.
That's interesting. All right.
Sit down. Sit down. Super People.
How many people got none, right? Could
you please rise? Absolutely none. I mean,
let's see how their moral man,
I wanted to know if anyone was just
totally blind and about 10 people were
totally blind. Got None right
at all. My wife got none.
Oh my God. Yeah,
she was amazed. So this is the thing.
So, so, so the question then becomes so,
so wow.
A lot of people really do have this
problem so that a lot of people who may be
leading lives of embarrassment and partial
disability and secrecy and shame and
I, uh,
I evolved all sorts of coping
mechanisms with a dyslexia,
um, many of which are
now taught, you know, to
people who have other problems. But I,
but there unfortunately
no real answers to,
uh, to coping with.
Well, you have some
charm it up high. I mean,
um, you're,
you're not going to lessen the deficit
by having a good attitude or trying
harder or whatever it is what it is.
[inaudible]
I want to thank the world science festival
to Brian Green and Tracy de who run
the thing. It comes every spring in New
York City. Lots of scientists. And boy,
does it come, it comes
like a comment. Yes.
And we over at Radiolab or the
Jed was there this year. He did a,
he did animals. Animals, yes. And
uh, like we haven't done that enough.
Well like, like we don't know faces
when it's the world science festival.
So will you say hello to the world? We
say thank you to science. Thank you.
Two festivals.
We know how to body with the best of
them and thank you to you for listening.
Thank you. I'm Jen. I'm Robert. See Ya.